we recently published a video that
talked about 99% of screenplays are
rejected after the first scene Hey
by most script readers so as someone who
is now starting to read scripts and and
has done in the past interning what
would you say to that I'd say I think my
most scripts get rejected after the
first scene is really because by the
first page you can tell if someone is a
good writer or not and if it's not going
to carry you through then there's
usually not a strong enough reason to
continue reading even if there's a great
story underneath it there's just too
much else out there that is a good story
and has the writing to back it up so
it's not that there's not something
great in there it's just that that
script is not at the level yet that it
should be in order to move forward into
a film so when you start reading a
script what are some things that turn
you off immediately not in terms of
formatting and and you know misspellings
but just how the story's structured for
me a big thing that will turn me off
pretty quickly is when I feel like the
characters aren't truthful when they're
not acting honestly as human beings do
then I feel like I don't have a steady
footing for how this story is gonna play
out because I'm not actually watching a
real human being go through their life
and so that'll probably the first thing
that that turns me off and it's gonna be
really tough for me to stick with it as
the story continues so it's not
necessarily a character who doesn't know
themselves well and thinks maybe they're
being altruistic but then they have
selfish reasons or whatever it is but
it's really that the writer wrote more
of a stiff character like a it's just
sort of too one-dimensional I think that
yeah one-dimensional
characters for me just don't feel real
and I'm as interested in reading a story
that has them how can you cuz I go when
I watched your trailer and in the
character she looks just like I believe
that that's a real person mm-hmm I saw
this person that I want to see her life
unfold even if it's tragic
she seems real to me if I were to be
reading something how would I see it
where I felt that that person was real
to me versus it was too fake I think for
me one of the keys to real characters is
specificity I think that people are
incredibly idiosyncratic with the way
that they moved through the world
everyone has their little ticks in their
things and their preferences and so the
more of those you can throw in to a
script on to a character is gonna make
that character feel real so whenever I
see that in the script I think that's
real person because I don't know anyone
like that and that's a specific thing
that a specific person would do that's
this specific person and now I'm gonna
watch them through the rest of the story
and if those specificities fit into a
larger theme that the film or show is
exploring then even better okay so if
you see someone that like I'm just
taking an example of someone I actually
saw at a pizza parlor and they didn't
want their pizza to be put into the oven
until they saw how it was cut and he
made a huge thing about it and I guess
they didn't listen to him and they put
it in and he was mad and just I didn't
want to like totally stare at the guy
but just that is a very specific you can
tell that that's probably how he
operates
yeah everything he does yeah and that's
that's a very specific thing and you
think it that sounds kind of crazy but
you saw someone in the real world do
that and you're telling me about it and
you were watching that and that was
drama to you so that was real life
specificity
think that we really respond to that so
if you can put that into your script
then people are going to respond to it
even though it's a fictional character
because we're still thinking well that's
a real person even if we know it's not
that's just sort of the way that we
empathize with characters so the more
specific and unique your characters are
even if it's just in little small ways
is gonna make them feel honest and real
and truthful I think did you have
moments as a script reader where you'd
read one page and be like I'm done
this isn't holding my interest there
were definitely times as a reader that I
would lose interest after page one but
my job was to finish it so I had to and
it's really tough to get through a
script when you're not interested in it
personally even if that's my assignment
that's my task and so I used to kind of
fight that and think that oh well I'm a
professional script area so I need to
look at this and figure out what's
working what's not working and put my
personal feelings about the script aside
but once I started realizing that my
emotional reactions to what was going on
in the script is actually a huge asset
because that's the thing that this
script is trying to do it's trying to
connect with an audience so once I
started listening to myself and
essentially using my emotions as the
tool for what was going on I could think
okay well I don't really care about this
character and then try to
reverse-engineer why I might not be
caring about that character and so
that's where all the craft and the study
would come in but that first thing that
really helped me in that job was
honestly just me David as a human am i
caring about this person do I hate this
person do I love it like do I want them
to get together with that guy at the end
or do I want them to not and if I don't
want them to get together but the script
I feel like is encouraging me to want
them to get together then there's
definitely a gap there and that gap is
where all the craft work comes in but
first I had to listen to myself how am I
feeling about these people about these
characters can you ever hate or dislike
a character and then toward the end
realize I
you liked them you misjudged them maybe
it was too close to home whatever it was
and then you realize actually they're
not that bad yeah absolutely
and I think that some of the best
scripts I read when I feel like I've
been taken on a ride and I haven't seen
the ride being built around me then
that's probably one of the best scripts
I would read and then on the flipside if
you ever read something where the
characters seem good and then toward the
end you realize even though they haven't
done maybe horrible things that they're
not the best people or there's something
there's a character flaw that you just
like yeah I think there are definitely
times that I've read scripts where I
liked the character off the bat and then
disliked them as it went on
and I think the difference between that
being intentional and that not in that
feeling not being intentional is where
the craft of screenwriting comes in is
it possible to have a horrible first
page and then it turns out the rest of
the script is actually great I don't
think I've ever read a script that has a
horrible first page and the rest is
great I have read scripts where I think
the first page is horrible and then
later on I realize like oh actually
here's what was going on I did the will
de Scott pulled over my eyes that was
actually a great first page that was
intentional misdirection that suddenly
happened to me but I've never read a
script where that first page was bad I
think it was bad and then the rest is
actually really great as a viewer have
you ever loved a film or enjoyed it and
wanted to go and look at the script and
then realized well the script really
didn't live up to how the movie ended up
turning out which was fantastic but
somehow within the production and with
the actors it just it just transformed
mm-hm
there definitely times I've seen films
that are great and I want to go I gotta
go check out that script how how was
that written and then I go and the
script doesn't seem
as great as the movie turned out to be
converse they have also seen films that
I thought were not really that great but
I had read the script I thought that's a
fantastic script so I think it's
definitely a collaborative process what
we do and understand that we don't have
control we don't have full control over
the project and that sometimes works to
our benefit because we can turn in
something that maybe isn't quite
delivering on the promises of what we
thought this project could be but
someone else can deliver that promise
and that's part of what I'm banking on
as a screenwriter that someone else can
make my work even better but also
sometimes if I think I have something
great that doesn't necessarily mean it's
going to translate and it's it's tough
to say who is ultimately responsible for
the finished product when there's so
many people that are collaborating
together and I think that's one of the
great things about the job but it I
think can also be tough sometimes when
you feel like I have this really great
thing and then you see it and you go
okay well that's what it is all right
that's the film I think there are a
number of reasons a film can succeed and
I think there are a number of reasons a
film can not succeed both commercially
and artistically and I think it's really
difficult to tell exactly where things
went wrong sometimes it is but a lot of
times it's sometimes tougher even if you
think it's this one thing that actually
might be a symptom and the cause might
actually be elsewhere interesting okay
okay so it seems like it's this but it's
not actually that okay mm-hmm I think
that a film or TV show just has so many
moving parts and other than the projects
that were involved in directly we can't
see all of those moving parts we just
see the finished product and it's really
tough to diagnose the machine as a whole
just from the thing
that comes out of it yeah you know I saw
a film just this weekend I don't want to
say the name of it because I loved it
and I want to bash it but in the
beginning it was too fast paced and the
editing it was too it was cut too fast
and I'm like oh I don't think I'm gonna
like this and then BAM something clicked
and it must have slowed down something
either I got used to it and I loved it
and I didn't want it to end but yeah I
had that initial feeling like oh I'm not
sure this is gonna work for me and then
it did but I couldn't tell you what it
was it was just that process of sitting
there seeing it and it just worked and I
took myself out of being the theater
goer and I'm now I'm in the story yeah
it'll be interesting if you were to
rewatch it how you feel about those
earlier things now that now that you
know coming down the line you're gonna
get really into it so it will be
interesting to see how that holds up on
a second viewing that's a good point
that's a good point yeah I'll have to
see it
you